Hey! Which will affect people on work and student visas
and their dependence.
The government says
it'll mean a reduction in numbers of more than 300,000.
At the moment,
foreign workers must earn a minimum of £26,200
to get a skilled worker visa.
That will now jump to over £38,000.
People working in health and social care,
who make up the bulk of visas,
will be exempt from the minimum salary rise,
but those same workers
will be banned from bringing dependence into the UK.
The head of the union
unison called the plans cruel and said
they spell disaster for the NHS and the care sector.
The home secretary said
immigration policy must be fair and sustainable.
With a look now at the detail
and at the political pressures on the government,
here's our political editor,
Chris Mason.
ST Cecilia's nursing home in Scarborough
this afternoon.
225 people work here,
35 from abroad.
The wider social care
sector has a vast number of vacancies.
Overseas staff are seen as crucial,
but net legal migration has ballooned
when the government promised it would fall.
Home secretary
the government wants to show it gets that.
For many this is unacceptable.
People are understandably worried about housing,
about GP appointments,
about school places.
And so the Home Secretary said
the government will stop overseas care workers
from bringing family dependents
and we will require care firms in England
to be regulated by the Care Quality Commission
in order for them to sponsor Visas.
He claimed he didn't think this would
cut the number of care workers coming here.
Second, we will stop immigration
undercutting the salary of British workers.
We will increase the skilled worker earnings threshold
by a third to 38,700 from next spring,
in line with the median
full term wage for those kinds of jobs.
That means some will need to earn more to get a visa.
Those working in health and social care will be exempt.
Allowing overseas workers to earn 20% less
in sectors with big staffing shortages is to end.
And allowing graduates to stay on after their course
will be reviewed.
And we will ensure people only bring dependents
who they can support financially.
By raising the minimum income for family visas
to the same threshold
as the minimum salary threshold for skills workers
38,700. That is an increase of £20,000.
300,000 fewer people will be eligible to come to the UK
than were coming last year.
This is the law.